[Music]
let's go to tina in los angeles what's
up tina
okay
how are you good how are you
oh doing well good good what's up so i
was wondering
should i keep using my credit cards and
building up my credit score i pay them
off right away um so i just should i
keep using those and then also um i've
been contributing to my 401k for almost
10 years now since i started working at
my and my current job and should i keep
contributing that or
contributing to that or should i stop
how much debt are you and tina
um well
along with my car i'm about 30 000
in debt okay what other debt do you have
other than the car
just the car and like a couple credit
cards okay but the credit cards are very
small yeah okay so to answer your first
question no you should not continue to
use the credit card to build your score
let me ask you why you want to build the
score
um it's just
financial advice from my parents it was
like you know yeah cash is half good to
have but also a good credit score is
also
really really good to have been there
been there that is how i grew up
learning about the credit score at 18
you got to get a credit card to build
the scores you can go into debt so you
can get more debt so you can get a good
score do you see the vicious cycle this
has created
yeah and so when it comes to the credit
score i uh you know i've lived with that
one for many many years obviously when i
got a mortgage you get a score again um
but as far as keeping the score and
keeping using the credit cards for that
you don't need it because we're not
going to go into car debt again
because debt is not your friend and it's
stealing from your paycheck every month
and as far as everything else goes you
can rent hotels you can rent cars you
can do all kinds of things with a debit
card do you have one of those yeah okay
so tonight what if we had an exercise
where we cut up the cards and tried to
live on our debit card and paid off
these credit cards and never looked back
okay does that sound fun to you
oh my gosh wow
is this excitement are you like that
sounds crazy
i was like yeah that's a little bit
crazy but i mean
we're crazy around that level
do you know why is it crazy about credit
cards for about five years i just barely
got them again because i think it's
crazy to be like in the matrix and
playing this game of what does fico
think about me am i credit worthy
i mean does that not sound a little
crazy here's the truth tina if we wrote
you a check for a million dollars
and you didn't use your credit card for
a month you just put that million
dollars in the bank in your bank your
credit score would go down
because credit score has nothing to do
with your financial position it has to
do with your love affair with debt
so let me walk you through what's going
to happen you are going to pay off all
of your debt and never look back
including the car loan what's your
income
i make 75 a year awesome okay what's the
car worth
um well when i got it it was
26. okay
so that's a reasonable car for your
income we say that we don't want more
than 50 of your income tied up in with
things and motors in them because they
go down in value what your card is doing
as we speak
so if you're following our plan which i
assume you're you're newer to this this
craziness
i just started listening to this show
about like a week and a half why did you
come to us tina what's happening in your
life
well um
i was i was in a very bad financial
place a few years ago and i just had two
babies
um so my credit went down and it took a
while until i got like some promotions
at work and that it started coming back
up but then i kind of noticed once my
income started going up
um the lifestyle i guess started going
up too i'm just like i'm not just like
uh you know i'm
i need to stop like i need to get get it
together
and um i was just looking for like some
financial um
how do i say this advice like and i went
on um the podcast app on apple and i
found you guys
that is awesome very cool we're so glad
you're here that's a huge step just to
hate the situation you're in most people
are comfortable sitting in their own
poop and i'm glad you've decided to take
a step in that direction so when it
comes to our plan we have a proven plan
called the baby steps 10 million people
have done this including myself
including john and it works
so a1 is getting a thousand dollars
saved for a starter emergency fund do
you have a thousand dollars in the bank
not yet
okay that's going to be our a1 if that
means selling stuff side hustles working
extra i don't care we're going to do
this in less than 30 days can you do
that
um yeah i can sell that i'm on salary so
i'm like on a fixed income you know
great that means you got to fix your
your unfixed expenses
true
what's your favorite place to go out to
eat tina what what is your like guilty
plea like i'm going if i'm getting take
out tonight on a friday here's where i'm
going oh my gosh sushi okay bye felicia
you're not gonna have sushi for a long
time new restaurant town is called
sucasa you're gonna eat in your house
tina
best restaurant in town it's a whole
experience you get to make your own food
you're to love it so you're going to get
on a budget we're going to help with
that because you're a new listener i'm
super excited on the plan we're going to
gift you one year financial peace
university as well as every dollar our
budgeting app so that you can make a
plan for every single one of these 75
thousand dollars coming in
and it is gonna be so freeing i know you
hear the word budget like gross no i'm
telling you this is permission to spend
and you're gonna feel so confident about
the next steps
so on top of the thousand dollar starter
then we're gonna move to getting rid of
all this debt using the debt snowball so
list out your debts smallest to largest
ignoring the interest rate does that
sound crazy too
a little bit good
because culture is normal so we got to
be a little weird don't we
right all right so we're going to list
them out smallest to largest make
minimum payments and all the debts and
attack that little one with a vengeance
probably those little credit cards right
mm-hmm yeah and then we're gonna cut
them up when they're paid off and say no
more
tina's the bank now tina's her own
lender
and once we do that we're going to beef
up that emergency fund to three to six
months
then we invest do you know what that
means tina
it means we're not going to invest until
then it means we're going to stop the
401k contributions also sounds crazy
right
a little bit yeah because i've been
building it up for almost 10 years i
know this is a crazy train it'll still
grow you'll you'll still get compound
growth what you put in there but right
now we need to make progress and we need
to change our behavior and you're doing
14 things at once which is what got you
here right right so let's try to do one
thing at a time with focused intensity
and if you hate it hey in six months
from now if you're not in a better
financial situation you can go back to
tina's plan eating sushi putting money
in the 401k putting everything on credit
cards and hoping for the best buy and
visa bigger buildings for themselves
with at your expense
okay will you do it will you do a
thought exercise with me
sure
you got two little ones right
i actually have three three how old are
they
uh 14
7 and 5. all right let's fast forward 18
months
and you've worked
maniacally you took a second job you had
somebody watch your kids on the weekends
because you started working you just
went bananas and paid this off
and you open your eyes
and you've got these three kids they're
18 months older
and you owe nobody anything
nothing
and you think about
sleep
and you think about being a little bit
less stressed of a mom
which allows you to get a little bit
closer to those kids because you're not
quite as radioactive and not quite you
don't have to spend quite as much time
numbing out on netflix and and whatever
else device is scrolling in front of you
just because you got to pass a day and
now you're out walking in the
neighborhood and you're smiling you see
what i'm saying you're talking about
changing your entire life
and it starts with you deciding i want
to be free
or let's get some sushi
right
[Laughter]
right why
tina how much are you investing in your
401k right now what percentage
6 is the company match that sucks you
should do 15. wouldn't that be better
you know what you can do when you don't
have payments you can invest more in
your 401k
right with a fully funded emergency
sushi till you're sick
we also have a roth too so i was like i
was starting to look into it but i
haven't gotten quite into it just yet
make a poster put it on the wall and say
i'm coming for you in the future
18 to 24 months from now when i'm out of
debt 30 months from now when i have that
fully funded emergency fund i'm gonna
come back stronger than ever
15
and then we're gonna be saving for kids
college we're gonna be paying off the
house can you imagine what future tina's
gonna be like
she's gonna eat so much sushi she's
gonna be sick
so hang on the line austin will pick up
we're going to gift you financial peace
university every dollar and some
homework for you go listen to episode 7
of my podcast the fine print all about
the dirty truth behind your credit score
it's you're going to be disgusted when
you find out